hundreds of protesters in Israel have
protested outside the private home of
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu in Tel
Aviv to demand the release of captives
being held in Gaza some demonstrators
set up tents with pictures of their
missing relatives anti-government
rallies have intensified across Israel
in recent weeks there is mounting
frustration against netanyahu's
government for failing to secure a deal
to release the remaining
captives he's a few houses away and and
look we're hopeful that he will find in
himself uh the the ability to be in
dialogue with us we're not protesting
here we're not demonstrating we're
simply reaching out to say enough is
enough there is a solution on the table
there are all the forces in the world to
help us to reach a deal and to bring
these people back home and we have to
have to have our voice heard on that and
we are here to make our voice heard and
if he can sleep quietly then we cannot
and we need to show that I speak to
Laura Khan she's in occupied East
Jerusalem Laura anger and frustration
have been mounting for some time against
the Israeli government are we heading to
a Tipping Point do you
think well there's certainly a pressure
cooker on Benjamin Netanyahu at the
moment we had U as you just showed
dozens of people camping outside his
home in kesaria north of Tel Aviv last
night we've reached out to the families
of captives there and those in
solidarity with them it's a big movement
they said they're still there they're
not moving and they're waiting for
Netanyahu to come out to speak to them
they say he's dragging his feet on the
issue of releasing captives and he has
two priorities they're in contradiction
with one another one of them is to to
continue tough military pressure on
Hamas until it's defeated in Gaza the
other is to release the captives they
say the latter is putting what the sorry
the military pressure is putting a huge
um is putting their lives in Peril it's
putting their lives in danger um so they
now want to p on the pressure on
Netanyahu um one of them is on hunger
strike one of the fathers of a captive
and they release a very strong statement
I'll read it out we've begged you this
on Friday for 105 days now we're
demanding stop the executions of
hostages it's about freeing hostages and
it's about saving lives but it's not
just there that he's under pressure
there's been weeks of protests
particularly in Tel Aviv in hostage
Square from tens of thousands of people
many have switched from just calling for
the release of captives two calling for
a ceasefire demanding a ceasefire in
order to release them not just there but
also inside his own War cabinet that was
handpicked by him and many are not going
along with the party line they're also
saying you cannot defeat Hamas
militarily in a short amount of time you
need to focus on the hostages we've also
had International pressure um as Alan
Fischer our reporter has just mentioned
from the US but also from Russia a
delegation from Hamas visited mosow Mel
bogdanov who's uh the deputy foreign
minister of Russia received them and he
spoke about the catastrophic
consequences of the war on Gaza the
catastrophic humanitarian issues inside
the strip he also said he wants to focus
and prioritize the the release of the
captives he's putting pressure on Hamas
but also it seems levered against
Netanyahu but they also want to focus on
three specific captives uh from Russia
that are currently being held at one of
them Andre kosov I met his mother just a
couple of days ago she says his life is
in Peril he needs medication he's relied
on this medication for many years and
she's joined these Mass protests for
many weeks demanding uh that not only is
he released but she says she won't
return back to St Petersburg until he is
okay thank you for that Laura Khan there
for us in occupied East
Jerusalem